oh god why the show-me is closed I am
seeing on the Pringle and ready to
mingle
what do we think of show manses romances
absolutely not I think Joe masses are
done I'm looking for a showmance there's
no there's no like two ways about I'm
excited to see the girls in the house
have you seen these guys on the show
like it's gonna be hard to resist I just
want to work out outside have the
cameras on me while I work out outside
so succeed to see the girls and work out
all my subscribers day was like don't be
a home don't be having sex on TV my
glasses are fogging up just the thought
of flirting no no no I don't know I
wouldn't never do that I'm married right
I would never do that besides you want
to have six daughters out front protests
in the show I have a girlfriend back
home we've been dating for seven years I
am gonna flirt with girls in the hotel
has the girlfriend given you permission
to flirt your way through the game no no
she's really upset wife and I already
asked her if I could dabble into a
showmance I'm sure she said no yeah she
wasn't having any of that my mom really
wants me to have a boyfriend
does she want you to have a boyfriend on
TV though you know I think I feel like
if I can't successfully execute dating
in the real world on my own look if I
can't even catch a text back why should
I think that trying to date on live
television as a good idea I'm completely
open to it I'm sure big brother has done
an amazing job making fine intelligent
beautiful women I don't think that
there's any guy that they're gonna put
in the house that's worth $500,000 and
actively avoiding what you for a
showmance I feel like if you're
attracted to somebody who can't help it
she's not good for my game she's got to
go to I'm open to meeting somebody nice
but the thing is like I want to play as
a strong independent woman you know
flirt man's that always works I'm gonna
make sure I have strong friendships
maybe like a Paul and Victor type thing
but showmance is definitely not will
kind of explore that a moment-by-moment
okay I'm not opposed to it but I'm not
looking for it